hey we're in the Toyota greenroom are
you awake with Samantha very she's
editor in chief of Glamour magazine and
this morning the magazine announced its
2019 women of the year
they include what a list you've gotten
no madam Barry you know it's great okay
they include World Cup champion Megan
Rapinoe film maker Ava Duvernay you go
Ava
environmental activist greta toon burg
they're all featured in the november
issue good morning to you Sam it's good
to have morning such a great day I mean
this is a good dynasty is one of my
favorite days of the year why we planned
this for months right I was wondering
your process of picking who goes it
because every year anything I don't know
who they're gonna pick this year I don't
know that are they're gonna come up with
eight but every year you do and every
year they're so great Ellison process
briefly how it works well you know it's
months in the planning and again it's of
the year so we look at across the board
across different industries which women
have made major differences this year
but I think one of the things that stood
out for us about all of these eight
women this year is that they're nine
groups they're not just making a
difference this year they're really
pushing the boundaries and standing up
for themselves and kind of I think a lot
of the women you see will have
generational impact for years to come
whether that's Greta who's you know 16
and this is changing how we the world
looks at climate change or Megan Rapinoe
who's really fighting for the next
generation of female soccer players in
in equal pay and Charlize Theron's
number one I love Charlize covered
number one to be shallow for just a
second I love Charlene's haircut I love
I just saw her on Sunday there was a
screening for the movie bombshell
she is knockout in it where she plays
megan kelly why did she make the list
for you this year she made the list
obviously she's got she has I got that
big movie out at the end of this year
we're really interested in it she's told
us on set about the hours of prosthetics
that it took to have her look like megan
kelly put that on to it but for us she's
also been behind the scenes doing a lot
of work in South Africa yes so with the
Charlize Theron foundation it has been a
very steady work for her and really
really trying to change the lives of a
lot of she grew up in South Africa she
keeps it really close to her and
she we really kind of in her interview
show highlight the work that she's been
doing there
we've just named some of them I think we
should name all of the women who made it
this year there you describe them as
warriors on the frontier lines of change
Yara Shahidi margaret atwood tory burch
and the women of races the Guardians but
let's go to one of my favorites which
would be that can you hand me Ava we got
it lovely
Ava Duvernay she made it because what
she's changing filmmaking and rep range
the game she's changed the game and
she's really changing what it means to
be represented on screen the stories
that she has told obviously this year
you know her Netflix documentary when
they see us was nominated for 16 Emmys
she's really changing what it means to
be a woman in film telling stories and
and she's such a great filmmaker and he
cares about the stories that she's
telling and the representation she's
doing so we talked to her about the
series it burneth Nixon for her it
wasn't about the 16 Emmy nominations it
was about changing the story of those
five men and telling the truth that many
people she believed didn't know the real
truth of what happened to the Central
Park five and she talks a lot about
inclusion as opposed to diversity she
says it really is a matter of inclusion
now before we went on guys Sam said to
me that this was her favorite covered
this is Megan Rapinoe I'd say this is
what it was a word to use saucy sassy
what's all it's all see I love it and
it's a great photo but why is this your
favorite well my favorite was cuz we
were out in two boats and I knew you
were on the ship I was on this shoot and
and we I was on the second book because
the boat that they were shooting this on
it could only really it was so small
could only hold the photographer and the
other time that the male approaches he's
a sauciness it's it's amazing we were
either sauciness we were in the next
boat which was a small boat watching
this all go down and I think when you're
doing a shoot like this outside you're
also you don't want anybody any members
of the public to usurp your cover so
you're trying to get you're trying to
get a great outdoor shot we were kind of
getting it closer to Lady Liberty maybe
over the line of where we should have
been and this Coast Guard came in
we were afraid they were gonna move us
and I don't know if they recognize that
amazing shock the pink hair but they
were like you're fine you're good the
shock of pink hair or the sauciness
I don't know Greta toon burg is
certainly this has certainly been her
moment her year she's 16 years old she
the youngest person who've been on the
list I her young woman now making a
bigger contribution than his past we we
have we you've seen actually in recent
years Malala was the University you're
seeing that these young women can really
really make change and I think what was
interesting when we were awarding Greta
is the amount of people that wanted to
give us the secondary interviews Al Gore
was trying to talk to us for the
magazine interview and Nancy's telling
that you can see my space so I think
what was interesting was that all of the
generations of people that wanted to
come to us and talk about how Greta had
made a difference so we talked to you
know those climate activists that are
many generations older than her Al
Gore's time McCartney's interesting and
then also you have we talked to a lot of
younger women globally young girls who
talked about how Greta had influenced
them and really has made them think
about climate change Margaret out what a
lot of people know her from Handmaid's
Tale but she's so much bigger than that
as we know she's the best storyteller
and when her interview is amazing and
she's just got this regal elegance about
her we shot her in Canada and I think
you know it was like we were having the
queen of Canada come just said and she's
a beautiful person with so many stories
to tell and when she talks everybody
stops and listens she's amazing
the last time you were here you were
talking about you were doing a different
kind of cover about size and that size
really does matter but you wanted to
step out of the box in terms of what we
normally see on covers you know glamour
doesn't do as many print edition so this
is a very special issue how did that
cover work for you um so we this is our
one print issue this year yeah and I
think when we think about it again
you're you're you're you're making
something special that will stay on
somebody's coffee table for a long time
so it's not a print issue that lasts for
a month
people can get the women of the Year
issue and they can keep it and and look
at it for you know six months or have on
the coffee table
and yes we're profiling the eight women
of the year but we also have some really
inspirational stories of women in the
rest of the magazine including the room
where it happens we talk to the women of
pen15 about where they create where they
create here about the show great yeah
great usually have to watch it it's
great yeah it's really good and we talk
to a lot of women as well in the issue
that met at women of the year so or
women of the year event is on November
11 11th in New York yeah yeah Veterans
Day Week the day before on November 10th
we have the women of the Year summit so
we have a lot of people coming for
conversations and interactions and
experiences and in the actual magazine
we talk to women that men and women of
the year event I went on to do great
things together and so you have you know
ally Raisman meeting Chrissy Teigen for
the first time at women of the year and
then they went on to do great things
Martha powers in their and so there's
these great stories of what actually
happens when you put brilliant women in
the room together it's always a great
event I mean in addition to good
networking it's just a very solid number
one I'd love to hear the speeches you
walk out of there always inspired by
something that you heard or you met
somebody that you wanted to meet and
just happens to be in the room but I
want to go back to the size issue for
just a second how did that do for you
what what kind of conversation did that
generate I think what was it so our
September issue which was supersize
inclusive of worse yeah and we talked
about the f-word and the plus-sized
fashion Awards what is meant it wasn't a
conversation that just stopped in
September we've had lots of designers
and fashion houses and people in the
industry come and talk to us about how
size inclusive is something that they
really care about this year and going
into 2020 the women that we covered put
on the cover Santa boo and Iskra we had
Center boo here she was amazing Santa by
Iskra and Yvonne and Alessandra this we
put the cover out a couple of weeks
before Fashion Week and in they were
booked solid for Fashion Week I saw them
walk and Tommy Hilfiger they were just
booked on so many of the shows and they
were like this is we've had the best
kind of Fashion Week that we've had
we've also had a lot of designers come
to us and talk to us about if they want
to extend their sizes what should they
be looking at so we did the plus-size
fashion awards and there's certain
things that an oversize 12 in the US are
looking for that they're not seeing in
the market whether that is I think they
see that there's a lot of athleisure
wear that's yes but they need some
really saucy work where rice I like that
word you talked about fashion for a
second Tory Burch made the list
she's amazing so do you just go by
because Tory Burch has been around for a
long time he's done amazing things for a
very long time but this is the first
time she's made the glamour of the Year
list why this year so we picked her this
year Reedy for the work that she's doing
around the Tory Burch foundation so this
year she's been working on the Tory
Burch Foundation which really underpins
a lot that of that she's doing in
fashion and design and it was a message
that we really cared about it was all
about women embracing their ambition so
she's been going around the country with
her foundation and not only asking women
to embrace their ambition but giving
money to young female entrepreneurs that
want to start businesses and that for us
was it's made it stand out to our
stories more than just a designer she
really wants to make an impact she
really is and as editor-in-chief why
does this particular issue and this
particular awards matter to you
personally as you're carrying on a great
tradition oh my god it's 29 years right
and I think this is one of my when I
took on the job last year this was
honestly one of the things I was so
excited about because there is I don't
know if there's an other awards that
really sits back and takes takes note of
what women have done over the course of
the year and really how they've made an
impact to the world so that I just love
that idea of really celebrating women
continuously and if you look back at the
roster of who's been celebrated right 29
years we've had like RBG and you know
every Oprah Oprah's me oh yeah like
amazing like amazing women in Clinton
Melania Williams we've honored every
amazing woman but the reality is every
year we got a new stack I was I mean I
was gonna say and every year you come up
with somebody new you never
ever options of having celebrating
really great fantastic women we Thank
You Samantha berry good luck on November
11th it's always a really good event
goodbye thank you the saying thank you